puentes imposibles de cruzar desde el
lunes varias carreteras entre canadá y
eeuu se han convertido en puntos de
encuentro de manifestantes que se oponen
a las nuevas medidas sanitarias aquí el
puente ambassador un paso estratégico
que une ontario en el lado canadiense
con detroit en el lado estadounidense la
cuna de la industria automovilística
ford toyota está el anti general motors
todos están ubicados en la región con
los bloqueos los camiones ya no pueden
viajar los transportistas ya no pueden
abastecer a estas empresas
esto pone en peligro y amenaza muchos
puestos de trabajo en michigan ya
sabemos que las empresas se están
ralentizando que otros están cerrando o
planean cerrar en los próximos días esto
debe terminar
la administración estadounidense pidió
al gobierno federal canadiense que actúe
el llamado convoy de la libertad lleva
15 días ocupando ottawa la capital
canadiense durante los cuales muchos
negocios se han visto obligados a cerrar
el primer ministro está reaccionando a
estas pérdidas económicas
la pax el impacto en las pequeñas
empresas en los fabricantes en las
cadenas de suministro continua y ya sea
por las barricadas en las fronteras ya
sea por la retención en ottawa nos
debemos a nosotros mismos hacer todo lo
que podamos juntos todos los diferentes
niveles de gobierno para detenerlo los
manifestantes tienen la intención de
continuar la protesta originalmente
contra las medidas sanitarias pero
parece cada vez más una oportunidad para
desafiar al primer ministro ya cinturón